welcome to this blitz video to winning
and okay let's do something different
yeah the London system it's not terribly
exciting but as sometimes feel that
people can't do underestimated and then
um what can get a good position
sometimes interesting c-5m taking as
interesting it's far more unbalanced
then playing c3 after c3y doesn't have
any job doesn't have much that he can
pose in terms of problems this is some
different matter though are interesting
so how do we go about this I can go I
can get way through here actually
eighty-three Queen takes Knight b5
that's an idea we should be five Bishop
d7 not so clearly
I can also play Queen d2 and then 95
interesting let's do this i'm not quite
sure the IEP has to take with the Queen
on c5 now otherwise I go before Johnson
oh I didn't think about that move but
that is right this is something that can
be considered even though isn't before
move Queen c 3 i'll just move the Queen
to anywhere yeah guess so
but where is this important ok I'm going
here
yeah I think he has to go all the way
back maybe a four but i'm not sure if
this is help
yeah the London system it can be
interesting it depends a lot on the
players if you with wide if you willing
to to play a little bit unconventional
like d takes you five then it can be an
interesting opening okay it takes be who
I can take the eight just being very
pragmatic about this let's do it a
before I can go Queenie fire keep the
material it looks a bad that looks a bit
and maybe I should have thought about
that for mode I mean a be for 25 it
might be objectively winning for white
but it is a messy position I think if I
would if I were blackie i would go for
that just try to irritate the hell out
of me yeah okay that was an average of
just played rupee one when why should be
almost winning the pawn and it's not
just the pawn ok didn't go for it it's
not just the porn it's also the position
in general doesn't look doesn't look
good I came with the pond see'em
irritating black
okay eat okay devour our third now draw
offered that's funny you wanted to hit
the resign button right no not going to
take a draw here the other resigning
also would be a little bit a little bit
too too soon but no players that were
going to take a draw here I could have
played rock chicks actually it was not
so name it was let's say lest you but
then it looks at first but probably
still not very good
yeah simple plan just develop Bishop d3
castles Goa form so yeah
okay maybe go for this Bishop f6 I have
you five and if he takes I'll play
Bishop c4 and then castle well maybe
queen t4 first I'm sure but if I looks
right anyway opening up the position
cannot be cannot be wrong some tix and i
also have a check on age three yeah
that's actually it looks good it's like
at Bishop e3 so next move I can just
very conveniently castle it's also no
reason not to take edge seven but ok I
want to cancel anything finally
thought Queen f5 coming but I'm quite
sure No we'll go g6 at some point that's
probably still good
g6 I can take a second pawn and it's
made checkmate they probably wanted to
finish this yeah DS t takes you five is
the only move that poses some problems
and it often catches people unawares 96
is good i think or e-cigs check t I'm
not so sure there are some issues here
if black takes with the Queen night b5
is interesting night a six and two even
Queen D for is an interesting try black
has slight issues here with sorting sort
of sorting his position yeah I'm
threatening to take on c5 and fork 1c7
and yeah it's not a very very convenient
position really is six maybe I go see
three possibly than before it's not like
winning or whatever but I think white is
a little bit better him he tried this
yeah i know it i went for this I think
he has to take with the Queen here now
and then we get somewhat similar
position where again I think white
should be a little bit better note that
with this 9 p-5 business I'm also ready
to potentially place you for the night
cannot easily be dislodged here no tea
for you and this just does not work I
think yeah so we got exactly this and
now this is really just a pawn for
nothing much yeah here thought this
could be an interesting practical tribe
Queenie 5 Quincy to hear and the engine
only gives white 0.7 which is not really
great considering that why does a a
piss-up should be six through k3 that so
that's a mess it's funny the engine
wants to go here that's very strong yeah
Computers Computers computer cell if who
gets taken this is very good for white
oops means that he has to go back and
then I've got very good control queena
for whatever so there was still I think
the better practical practical try now
here this is just losing the key for was
a good idea maybe not the best move I
don't know where the engine responds to
take g7 as you could expect you it
probably was was ok but yeah it's not
the kind of move you like to play as a
human player this looks so check looks
better yeah yes to go g6 and something
jealous and yeah this is what I expected
and white has two points now but still
it has to be one opposite colored
bishops simply am only only possible
continuation he really really didn't
have much of a much of a choice there ok
thanks for watching